my mom tells him what's going on
something's not right will you just go
do a well-being check over there please
we wait there within 10 minutes a whole
slew of police officers run out the door
you you see that yeah and you know
what's coming it was her she had been
dead in that garage for 5 to six days in
July no he just killed her and left her
in there where in the car or where do
you even know outside of the car she was
laying in the garage was this a school
day I don't
know oh a school day you and your mom
went to find her missing friend and you
open the garage and she's dead in the
garage smelled her Fu and you can still
smell that
smell
Jesus the Honeydew with y'all subscribe
today